what are your first steps in the
screenwriting process I think the first
steps when I when I begin to write is a
lot of thinking about thinking about it
like I don't I'm not really good at just
sitting down and starting to bang it out
and I don't really often times I don't
write an outline it's not like I have to
make an outline first and then write the
script so for me usually it's a couple
of ideas that just won't go away
and so if those ideas won't go away then
that means that there's something
hopefully there's something there and I
just let it percolate and it has a sort
of magnetic if it's a good idea and
these are rare because it's not like I
have like never been one of those guys
that just like you know I was able to
spin a good yarn and have a million
stories I want to tell but in the case
of search and rescue it was just a
couple of ideas started to sort of bind
together and I think some of them were
ideas that I had for other movies that
didn't go anywhere like in other words
they were that's and it's now that I
think about it they were there were
several different ideas and characters
that had been I had been developing for
other movies that didn't sustain
themselves they were good but they
didn't for some reason they didn't
belong and whatever movie I was thinking
I was trying to make and so it all
started to kind of combine into this one
film but you know what I you know that's
specific to this particular movie and
every writing every writing process is
different you know if somebody comes to
me and says I need you to write
megashark versus giant octopus in two
weeks that's a different that's a
different process that's when you sit
down and you know figure out you know
okay act one this that should happen
then this should you know that's when I
do that so so you know work-for-hire
that has to be of a you know i think
that's easier as a simpler genre is
easier to do than this but i really did
have to think about it and i really did
have to draw from a lot of things that
had been dormant ideas that had been
dormant that sort of all sort of
coalesced to form this thing that's how
it started then I didn't then of course
I had to sit down and write every day
like everybody else you have to write it
you know you can think about it all day
woman but you have to write it did you
have dedicated time stuff I did I just I
finally you know I kept talking about it
and my wife was finally like you need to
write this thing you just need to do it
you know and went certainly without
Valerie's you know insisting that I just
you know get down to it I probably
wouldn't have done it but I did I just
basically realized that if I got up at
you know 5:00 in the morning every day
that I would be in this kind of you know
a lot of writers talk about that this is
this kind of like haze well you're not
really judging you're not in a critical
mind you're just sort of in a semi dream
state that if I got up at 5:00 and wrote
for like till 9:00 or something like
that you know if I wrote for three or
four hours in the morning that I could
bang out you know without me judging
myself I would just knock out you know
four pages or three or four or five it
was a good day
and I just did that you know over you
know however long it was a month I just
just every day just knocked out a little
bit so at least you know after if you do
the math I mean five pages a day at
times twenty days what honored pages so
in with inside of a month you can get a
draft done and then you go back and
you're like oh this is and this
doesn't work and you actually are able
to tackle it critically but at least the
hard part of just getting it out was
accomplished if I was diligent and got
up and just did it and that's hard you
know it's like going to the gym or
whatever it's not that that takes you
know anybody will tell you that's and
some days you don't have anything
sometimes you just sit there you know
and you're just like you know I got one
line but I think as all writers or real
writers will tell you that's like what's
necessary the writer writes you can't
expect to just not do it and then have
great stuff pour out you have to go to
the gym you know so that's how it that's
how it happened you said something
earlier about you have a friend who's a
real writer writer and I was just
wondering how how is that different how
what is a real writer writer I think a
real writer writer or someone who just
writes all the time like that's what
they do it's not even about like making
physically making the movie it's about
writing it's like they write one script
and then they start
working on the next script where they
write one novel and they're already
outlining the next novel they're just
what I considered dyed-in-the-wool
writers the way that are not - it you
know writer directors or whatever
they're just writers and I have real
respect for that because you know it's
like it's very myopic it's like this is
their skill you know and it's a very
difficult thing to be a good writer so I
have a lot of respect for that you know
I I'm a writer I don't think I'm a
writer naturally I'm a writer out of
necessity in other words I became a
writer because I couldn't expect
screenplays to fall out of the sky for
me to direct so I became a writer so I
could have some control over the the
film's I wanted to make but I feel like
it was a longer process to become a
pretty good writer whereas being a
director felt more natural to me I just
had a more natural instinct for it
whereas writing felt like work you know
and writing still feels like work to a
certain extent feels like you really
whereas when I'm making a film even
though it's hard it never feels like I
never feels like work it just feels like
you know natural for some reason so I
feel like the writers that that are real
writers are the ones that this that they
speak that language they hear that music
that's their that's their way primary
way of expressing themselves
you